YOURS.
TOM: GREAT TO SEE HERE EVERYBODY
FINALLY LIVE AT THE PRUDENTIAL
CENTER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I WANT TO THANK ALL OUR STAFF
BEHIND ME FOR ALL THEIR TIRELESS
WORK THEY'VE PUT IN THESE LAST
TWO YEARS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WITH THE FOURTH OVERALL PICK THE
NEW JERSEY DEVILS ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT -- TO PICK FROM THE
U.S.A. DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM LUKE
HUGHES.
JOHN: THERE IT IS.
REMEMBER, HE SUSTAINED THAT
LACERATED TENDON IN MARCH.
HE GOT CUT BY A SKATE.
HE MISSED THE U-18'S.
ON HIS WAY TO MICHIGAN TO JOIN
THAT STAR-STUDDED CAST.
PLENTY OF INSULATION IN TERMS OF
TALENT AND OBVIOUSLY DRIVEN
PERSONALITY.
HE WILL WORK ON HIS GAME AND BE
ON A TEAM THINKING ABOUT A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND YEAH, THEY ARE PUMPED,
AREN'T THEY?
THAT SAVES A LOT OF AIRLINE
MILES.
JEFF: HE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PLAY WITH HIS BROTHER.
TO WALK INTO THE NHL AND SOME
BRAGGING RIGHTS OVER ONE
BROTHER, MAYBE NOT OVER THE
OTHER, RIGHT?
I THINK THE ONLY DOWNSIDE IS
THERE ARE NO MANY HUGHES
BROTHERS, RIGHT?
JOHN: EXACTLY.
JEFF: THIS IS A SPECIAL TIME FOR
THE HUGHES FAMILY.
IT'S A PRETTY HIGH END CALIBER
TO PLAY WITH HIS BROTHER.
JOHN: I LOVE TO SEE THE JOY --
JACK IS SO CALM.
SO MANY FAMILIES HAVE THESE
JEALOUSIES AND THESE FIGHTS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE PURE LOVE.
THEY'RE SO HAPPY FOR THEIR
BROTHER.
MAN, THAT'S THE BEST.
KEVIN: THAT'S POWERFUL STUFF
RIGHT THERE.
POWERFUL STUFF.
JEFF: YOU COULD TELL THAT HE WAS
LIGHT ON SKATES.
BUT HE'S GROWN IN LEAPS AND
BOUNDS.
YOU THINK WITH HIM BEING ONE OF
THE YOUNGER PLAYERS IN THE ELITE
THAT THAT TRAJECTORY WILL
CONTINUE AND THAT 45 DEGREE
ANGLE.
SO THE FEELING IS MASSIVE FOR
THIS GUY.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT HIM IS
HE PLAYED A LARGE POSITION OF
THE SEASON ON HIS OFF-SIDE.
WHEN HE TRANSITIONS TO THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE, THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE SURPRISE FOR
HIM.
RIGHT-HANDED DEFENSEMEN ALWAYS
DIFFICULT TO PLAY WITH.
HE CAN PLAY THE LEFT SIDE AS
WELL AS AN ADDED VALUE TO THE
PLAYER.
HERE'S SOMETHING SIMILAR THAT HE
DOES LIKE HIS BROTHERS.
EXTREME AMOUNT OF CONFIDENCE
WITH THE PUCK AT ANY TIME.
I'LL TAKE IT INTO THE ZONE.
I'M QUFT THE PUCK.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO DO A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THE SAME THING.
NO PROBLEM GET IT DOWN TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
HEY, JACK HUGHES, THIS LOOKS
FAMILIAR.
I'M GOING TO CUT IT BACK TOWARDS
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
YEP, DISH IT OFF THAT TEASE
SNIPE FOR THE NEW JERSEY DEVIL.
SO THE FOUNDATION FOR ALL OF THE
HUGHES BROTHERS IS BASED ON THAT
GREAT SKATING ABILITY THEIR EDGE
WORK, THEIR ABILITY TO TURN ON A
DIME THAT MOBILITY IS SIMPLY
FANTASTIC, IT WORKS WELL IN
TODAY'S TRANSITIONAL GAME.
THE OTHER PART IS THAT QUFTS THE
PUCK, THE ABILITY TO DO TPWHIG
THE PUCK AT ANY TIME.
THEY'VE ALL COMPETED AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER.
SO IT'S ALWAYS GOING AGAINST THE
HIGH LEVEL OF COMPETITION WITHIN
THE FAMILY.
WEEKESY?
KEVIN: ALWAYS HAS TO FIGHT --
TOTALLY, NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE'S A
TWO-WAY DEFENSEMAN.
HE'S GIFTED ENOUGH TO GENERATE
OFFENSE.
HE CAN BEAT THE FORECHECK
HIMSELF.
HE CAN ACTIVATE IN THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE LIKE A FORWARD.
BUT DEFENSIVELY, HE WANTS A
MATCHUP.
HE WANTS TO KILL PENALTIES.
HE WANTS TO DO THESE THINGS AND
BE MORE OF AN OVERALL
DEFENSEMAN.
WHAT A TIME FOR THEIR FAMILY.
I REMEMBER BEING UP THE ROAD IN
THE PRUDENTIAL CENTER WHEN THEY
UNVEILED HIS BROTHER AS THE
NUMBER ONE PICK.
JEFF: THEY ALL LOOK 15.
SO IT TELLS ME THAT THERE'S ROOM
FOR GROWTH.
THEY'RE SO GOOD AND TALENTED BUT
LOTS OF ROOM FOR GROWTH AS A
GENERAL MANAGER.
YOU DON'T WANT A GUY WITH A FULL
BEARD SHOWING UP.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: I'M PUMPED THAT HE'S
PLAYING IN MICHIGAN, FROZEN
FOUR.
QUINN BROUGHT MICHIGAN TO THE
FROZEN FOUR.
DIDN'T QUITE GET THE J